françois 1 fois ça y est oui je sais le
métier que je vais faire plus tard
maintenant tu en es sur wii du vauxhall
10 à temps et entend casimir ça va faire
quelque chose de beaucoup mieux je vais
appeler les enfants et du van hool mi
mai ah oui ça c'est une bonne idée alors
les enfants venus bits
je vais vous faire un mime ça va être
prêts pour la lte a tant mieux parce que
vous aussi vous allez chercher le métier
que casimir va me met d'accord
bon alors ça y est vous êtes prête
vas-y casimir sans doute on mime il faut
trouver le métier de casimir 1 alors
regardez bien non on attend la fin du
mime
on ne dit rien pendant le mine et à la
fin du mime au denier réponse on le
laisse aller au bout voilà il y en a qui
ont trouvé là laetitia fender cessa
footballeur tout le monde a trouvée et
puis les gars sont bons casimir casimir
nous en fait un autre moyen d'inflation
assieds toi fils et m'a bien faire ah
c'est ça regarde bien après le
footballeur que faire casimir l'homme et
biot à yale roy ont la faire un petit
peu parce qu'il sera tellement déçu si
on trouvait tout de suite mais je ne
m'appelle pas monsieur gilles en face
oui alors qu en ligne fait jouer la
balle au mur ça ressemble à ses parrains
me dit oui qu'à dijon parce que ces
jongleurs c'est ça c'est ça
voici les dix jours
mais ce qui nous fait amim donc il nous
fait aimer les enfants caroline caroline
et cécile alors prenez la place
prenez la ps2 casimir aller casimir tu
regardais le deviner avec nous laëtitia
est carré bien les gestes très important
le mime
on ne dit rien du tout faits uniquement
des gestes cherchez bien chez vous un
regard des noms mais il me dit rien vous
les troubles et non non il faut les
laisser faire calmement un jean-marc
regarde très très bien ce qu'elle fait
caroline ne dit rien ne dit rien rypien
d'einstein tiens voilà
regardez bien chez vous observez bien
tous les gestes de caroline voilà c'est
fait car les ans ils sont bien
maquilleuse c'est ça c'était maquilleuse
et chez vous vous aviez trouvé parfait
ya midi à casimir marianne propre
histoire
alors vous laissez faire tranquillement
1 à ziad aziz sy tokpanou encore un
petit peu stop court aulas est trop
petit pour ça c'est la trouvais pic
alors exclu explique ce qui ne l'est pas
et explique si tu connais pas le nom qui
mois cécile alors caroline couturier
s'est passé et j'y vois aiguiseur raider
c'est sayan eia ne veut être rémouleur
rémouleur le coup tu sais très bien mais
et toi françois pourquoi tu ne nous
ferait pas un mime mimer un métier ouais
c'est quasi mais il ya tellement de
métier que j'aimerais faire que je sais
pas lequel choisir
ce que je voudrais faire je te chanter
ah d'accord
ouais c'est ce que je voudrais
non
il vraiment
il
ou très grand
j'aime
m
les fourmis les sourires ont des vies
extraordinaires
je
voudrait
n'explique ses mystères je voudrais être
très savants que d'être le secret des
choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants roses quelqu'un a t'il deviner
ce qu'on trouve au delà des étals il
voit ton parfois des lions des hommes
s'ils gagnent les oiseaux les corbeaux
et les marches tout heureux
les canards
le
là
découvrant les dauphins l'est marceau
qui sont de vrais mammifères
son
comme mon dégoût
r je voudrais être très savants
connaître le secret des choses et y
at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants roses quelqu'un a pu deviner
ce qu'on trouve au delà des épaules il
voit tant par pas des lions des hommes
segal très
c'est ce que je voudrais
il est vrai
[Musique]
non
allah
[Musique]